hey what's up guys my name is a chino
and welcome to episode 98 of game
programming okay it's crazy how long
it's been since the last episode but you
know university is kind of getting the
better of me but universities almost
over so you guys should see a lot more
videos coming up shortly as i go onto my
summer holidays in fact i should be able
to release an episode of game
programming every few days or so now
instead of every few weeks so definitely
look forward to that so today we're
gonna start on a on quite a long series
of videos in which we're gonna basically
implement the a style search algorithm
now the a star search algorithm is a
path finding algorithm that essentially
helps i guess well enables you to get
from point A to point B in the shortest
path possible of course going around
things like obstacles and and again
taking the lowest cost path path so
meaning if you have stuff like mud which
slows you down it might try and work
around that so it's very intelligent and
it's very good and we're gonna implement
it eventually okay but there's a lot of
steps that need to be taken before we
can implement it so right now what we've
got going on is this game of course
called rain we've got all these just
random ambient qingchun o
AIS and then we've got this red evil one
which Tech which chases you know player
moves insanely fast right now so we can
run out of his range and you can see he
stops chasing house so that that stuff
is working great but the problem that we
really want to solve right now is
basically if we want to get our AI to
move from point A which is right here to
point B which is where my mouse cursor
is he's just not gonna be able to do
that right he's just gonna try and go
like this and then he'll actually like
the wall will stop him from getting
there okay so we need to somehow get him
to be able to create a path around this
obstacle right so that he can go like
this and be like I made it alright that
that that's our goal essentially so to
achieve this we'll be using the a-star
search algorithm now there are a lot of
algorithms that will do this but a-star
is one of the most efficient and popular
ones so we'll be doing that one now
that's all good but in order to actually
implement the a style search algorithm
we have a lot of things that we need to
actually prepare for that okay and also
it is it's quite a complicated algorithm
especially if you've never done
pathfinding before so um that's why I'm
going to be making sure to explain all
of it in as much detail as possible
alright so first off what we need to do
is make a vector class and that's what
this video is gonna be about vectors now
we haven't we've kind of been avoiding
using vectors so far in this game and
really by avoiding using vectors I don't
mean we have been using them technically
we just haven't been actually making a
class for them and stuff like that and
that's really quite a popular thing to
do and the reason is I didn't want to
really complicate this but now we
actually pretty much have to make a
class for it so write it right now I'm
just I'm actually just gonna make
another folder here so on the rain when
new right click new whoops look out of
that right click new folder and I'll
call that I'll call that utila care
since for utilities this is just gonna
be a black kind of like tool classes
right so like tools so that we can um so
that we can uh well I guess help helper
classes that will help us with stuff
like maths so we'll call this one vector
2i I can I'll explain what the hell -
and I'm ends in a mess so if we had to
finish on that and we've got a class so
what on earth is this - an eye thing ok
so first of all we have vector right
this is just like a little convention
with a little naming convention we have
vector we have which obviously means
that this class is a vector like our or
this class will contain a vector we have
to which means that this vector will
have two coordinates as in the
coordinate system is based on two points
which means it's two-dimensional
essentially if it was three would have
three so X Y Z 2 means x and y and I of
course is the type of data that is
stored in this vector i standing for
integer if we were using doubles we'd
hit dave if we were using floats would
here f floats are pretty popular
as well we absolutely don't need and
we're not using anything like OpenGL or
anything so vector 2i okay so that's
actually how do we create a vector right
so the way that we've created vector is
by creating a new instance of this
vector class so when it we need a
constructor that will actually allow us
to construct this vector so let's have a
public vector - I like we would make any
other constructor and in the parameter
I'm going to hit up into X and in Y okay
so what does little what does let's odds
do is actually create a new vector 2i
with two parameters X and y now x and y
of course will refer to what this vector
actually is all right so - in order to
actually I guess you know apply these we
have to of course make variables two
variables in our class private int X & Y
now you know this is pretty standard
procedure so I'm not going to spend too
long on this but in order to of course
set the X that we specify in the
parameter to the ones set to this class
we simply hit up this dot X which refers
to X and the reason we have to use it
this keyword obviously is because these
have the same name so we need to tell
Java which one we're referring to and
this is a wykel's Y all right and that's
pretty much it right that's our basic
vector class you could make this public
and do some of that but I'm rather than
doing that I'm actually just gonna make
getters and setters just because in fact
I'm thinking right now if I should in
that there's a lot of debate as to would
as to whether you should or not because
this is the other thing I want to
quickly mention if we were to make
something like public int get X okay and
what that would do is return X and then
we would have make something like public
and get sorry set X right and it doesn't
have been in public void set X and X and
of course at this time X equal to X
would that really be you know necessary
as in because we've set both of them so
why not just make this public and then
we'd be able to you know modify it
basically without having to call these
methods that's an idea and that's really
up to you but
we're gonna do it this way because I'm
going to show you guys a little trick as
well so we'll keep this private and with
these things right the usage might be a
bit you'll see you'll see this in a
minute actually let me first type is out
so public int get X will of course
return the X component of the vector
public and get Y it will return the Y
component of the vector public avoid a
set X will set the X and of course
public would set Y will set the Y
alright pretty simple stuff now right
now these can return void and that's
cool I guess but in practical usage it
might not be very I guess I don't have
fun okay let's just consider a quick
scenario yeah so public let's call it
public void test right and this is just
like I'll delete this in a minute this
is just here so I can demonstrate the
usage so let's just say we want to make
a new vector all right we'll call this
like player position or something right
so if that was called position and not
complicate things vector 2i position
equals new vector 2i and then we'll make
the position let's just say 80/40 ok so
it's almost like a tall coordinate in
fact this is this probably would be at
our coordinate all right we've met a new
position now let's just say or suddenly
we want to set the position to oh I
don't know let's just say well let's
just say we want to set the X to be like
15 suddenly instead of 80 but that's
kind of boring right what we could also
do okay
it's let's just say we want to do
something like again this is kind of
useless for this scenario but just bear
with me if we wanted to do something
like vector 2i dot set X like straight
away then what we could do is set the
return type of set X instead of being
void to be vector 2i all right and then
at the end simply return this
now this allows us to use the method as
a simple set X if we require it to yeah
and that'll be fine obviously or it
actually allows us to modify it here now
why is that useful willing this
case it's not extremely useful because
we can set it in the parameter but in
some cases it's it can be useful I'll
demonstrate that in a minute here
because we haven't finished without
vector class yet return thus pretend
this alright cool so now that we made it
I guess a really basic way of creating a
new vector let's go ahead and make
another way of creating a vector so
vector 2i and this time we won't use any
parameters so what this will do is set
this dot X equal to 0 and this dot y
equal to 0
okay so what this is doing is it's
creating a new vector but with a
location of 0 0 all right and then we
have this little thing now where it's
like okay we're setting both of these
twice color repetition kind of not
really so why not make a public avoid
set which sets in to X and in Y so this
so x equals x this don't like or what
equals y and then instead of having to
do this we can simply go ahead and set X
Y and set X Y what's set 0 0 that's what
I'm at of course all right cool
so well so basically I guess this is
almost a tutorial on how to make a good
utility class right this can this can
pretty much handle anything without it
now but not quite ok so there's one more
way that I want to explore as to how we
want to maybe that maybe make a vector
okay and that is off an existing vector
so let's just say we've got a vector and
we want to make another vector that is
based on this vector alright so public
vector 2i and I'll take a vector 2i as
the parameter all right and we'll simply
set backs without X vector dot Y ok so
what we've done here is we've made an
existing value so you can see that May
through opposition and we want to maybe
let's just say we want to set if this if
this would it be the player position and
it excuse the use of underscores just
because it makes it a bit easier to see
here since it's a long word so we've got
Marvel position we've got plate
opposition we want to set the most
position
to be player possession but on the other
hand we do want it to be its own vector
okay because clearly these two should
not have the same instance otherwise the
player will always be able to get into
the mob and vice versa so we'll make a
new vector2 why but we'll simply feed
off the player position all right cool
so what we've done now is we've created
a brand new vector which contains the
mob position but we've created it based
off the player position but it is its
own vector so when the mob moves the
player position won't be affected at all
now that here's where the vector return
type comes in very useful if we want to
be like yeah okay we want to make we
want to make this at the player's
position but maybe I want to change the
X so I want to make it based off the
players Y but let's just change the X we
can go ahead and go set X 50 all right
just like that and now that'll be final
obviously so that's that's a cool thing
that you could do as well now of course
you could always do it like this but and
that's pretty boring let's be honest and
also doing it this way allows us to be
in one line of code rather than having
this which is the same effect in the end
but requires two lines of code so that
is pretty much gonna wrap up is vector
class almost now we're gonna get into
the more juicy stuff about factors and
that is stuff like addition subtraction
dot product cross product all that good
stuff what I'm going to deal with dog
cross product yet I don't think we'll
even need them anytime soon in this
series but I'll leave this here for now
but adding and subtracting vectors is
incredibly easy okay so we've got add
let's just say we want to add a vector
to another vector so vector we're going
to add a vector to this vector alright
all we have to do is go this dot X plus
equals vector dot X all right and this
star y plus equals vector Y really
simple stuff and we'll do the exact same
thing and here is where we can also set
the return type to the vector 2i so for
example I don't know what again why
you'd want this but you could have
scenario in which you have the play a
happy created mob position and then you
go ahead and go okay what creating in my
position based on the player's position
but we'll double it so we'll end up with
something like that and that'll be fine
so you know infinite scenarios here
really and of course we need to return
this and then subtract and it's going to
copy and paste it's to subtract will be
the same so subtract to subtract a
vector we of course change this to
multiply - sorry - - now Dalton cross
product are a bit different dot product
I don't think is much different but
cross products are very different so
we're not going to deal with them today
and I think we'll need them for a while
anyway
but that's gonna pretty much wrap up
this episode of game programming I hope
you guys learned something cuz we'll be
using this stuff extensively in the a
style search algorithm because rather
than using tile positions see this is
the other thing I want to quickly
mention this vector class is gonna be
the backbone for any kind of location in
the future okay and the reason is it
enables us to store true variables in
one class as well as gives us awesome
ash awesome access to functions such as
these okay
now that being said and that being said
the reason we even need a vector class
now I still search algorithm is if we go
into level real quick I'll just open up
the level 2 Java class you can see over
here that when we get tiles we're
returning a static objects when I rotate
we're not actually returning instances
now because our tiles are not separate
instances they're actually already
defined as static instances in other
words there is only one instance of a
grass tile
it just gets rendered everywhere it just
gets read everytime we render you know
an array of grass tiles right the actual
object there's only one instance of it
because of that a tile does not have an
x and y okay I know there's an x and y
here I don't think did we actually use
that if I remove that what scream no
exactly let's just remove that a tile
does not have an x and y okay a tile is
just a sprite and you know it contains
water is solid on
and it contains a method to actually
render it to the screen a sprite does
not have an X and y coordinate because
it doesn't have that we need something
to keep track of whether sprite what
where the tile actually is and we do
have this wonderful get tile which will
actually check if the tiles that are is
that a coordinate and return it to us
but we still need a vector so that we
can build a path okay so that's that is
the relation of vector to I to our a
style algorithm and hopefully with an
episode again program we'll be able to
actually start possibly talking about at
the actual algorithm so yeah but anyway
this back to class was very very
important I hope you guys enjoy this
video please hit the like button the
more likes this gets the more likely I
am to actually post another episode and
the reason is it just motivates me so
feel free to hit the like button and
leave a comment if you're having some
trouble if you are actually having some
serious trouble and it's requires more
than like ten words to describe head
over to the Cherno comm and the link
will be in the description and if you go
to the forum's section you actually be
able to post and definitely get a reply
all right
guaranteed literally there is not a
single post there that has not had any
replies so um yeah but other than that
guys I will see you guys the next time
goodbye
you